PROFESSOR: Today, we
continue with scattering.
And we begin by reviewing
what were the main ideas that
have already been explored.
And here they are.
I've summarized the main
results on the blackboard.
And we begin with an
expansion of our solutions
for the case of
central potentials.
This psi effect
represents a solution away
from the scattering center.
The scattering
center is this region
where there is a potential
that the particles fill.
And this solution that
we've written on top
is a solution written
for spherically symmetric
potentials in the case
that the potential is 0.
That is, that solution is
valid away from the potential.
We constructed it with the
free particle solutions--
the jl and the nl of kr--
of the spherical Schrodinger
or radial Schrodinger equation.
In particular, we
identified these objects
called phase shifts
that we discussed
in the process of scattering
with spherical waves.
And the result is that the
way we introduce the phase
shifts, the tangent
of the phase shift
is determined by the ratio
of these two coefficients, Bl
over Al.
So there's a phase
shift for every value
of l beginning from l equals 0.
Then we have that given that
relation, the solution above,
when you use asymptotic
expansions for jl and nl,
takes that form with a sine
of kr minus l pi over 2
plus a phase shift, which
is another way where
you can read the phase
shift of your solution.
We're going to focus today for
a little while in understanding
the physics of the
phase shifts and how
you find the phase shifts.
But supposing you
find the phase shifts
and that was the derivation that
was very non-trivial that we
did last time, we find what
this scattering amplitude
is in terms of the phase shift.
So this was our main hard work
establishing that formula.
Once you have that formula,
that f of k in preliminary work
was shown to represent the
scattering solution far
away from the source.
Far away from the source
we have the incoming wave
and the outgoing spherical
wave modulated by fk of theta.
Now, in general, you can
have an fk of theta and phi,
but then the phase shift method
is not quite suitable for that.
For that, we will discuss
some other methods today
that can allow us to do that.
So once you have this f of k,
you know the wave far away.
You know how it contributes
to the cross-section,
and you know how
the phase shifts.
Each phase shift contributes
to a total cross-section,
which is given here.
So these were our main results.
So let's leave this
results here and discuss
your general computation
of a phase shift.
You're given a problem, maybe
like the problems in the p set,
and you need to find
the phase shift.
So where do you begin?
There's nothing in
there that seems
to say, OK, this
is the way you're
going to find the phase shit.
So let's do this general
computation of the phase shift.
Computation of the phase shifts.
So I think you all know--
and there's clear intuition--
that if you want to figure out
the phase shift,
at some point you
have to look at this
region, r less than a,
where the potential is.
Because after all, the phase
shift depends on the potential.
So that's unavoidable.
You have to get dirty with
that potential and solve it.
So what is the equation
that you have to solve?
It's the radial
Schrodinger equation.
So you have to solve--
you set energy in the
Schrodinger equation equal h
squared k squared
over 2m because we're
using k from the
beginning to represent
the energy of the state.
So energy is going to be that.
And the radial
Schrodinger equation
is minus h squared
over 2m, d second dr
squared plus the potential.
Finally, the potential shows up.
You have to solve that.
Plus the potential centrifugal
barrier, h squared l times l
plus 1 over 2m r squared.
All that acting on
a solution u sub l--
I will put the k as well of r--
equal the energy,
which is h squared
k squared over 2m ulk of r.
So this step cannot be avoided.
You have to solve it.
You have to solve this equation.
So you solve this
for r less than a.
This for r less than a.
You have some hints
of what you're
going to encounter because
you know from solving
radial equations that ul
behaves like r to the l plus 1
as r goes to 0.
That's a boundary condition
for the l-th wave.
And well, with that, you're
supposed to solve for this ul.
OK.
So you solve for this ul.
And so what?
Where are the phase shifts?
You're done with it.
And you need to know where
are the phase shifts.
Well, remember our
notation is that we have
a radial function, l of k of r.
In the radial equation you
know that the radial part
of the solution of the
Schrodinger equation is--
the full solution
is a radial part.
So ylm.
In this case, yl0.
But this radial thing
is ulk of r over r.
That is presumably something
you still remember,
that the radial
solution was u over r.
OK.
So you've solved it.
You've got this quantity.
And you say, all right,
what do I do next?
Well, what you
have to do next is
to match to the solutions
that lie outside.
There is these solutions that
hold for r greater than a,
where the potential is 0.
So those have to be
matched to this solution.
So let me draw a little diagram.
We have diagram for r.
And here is a.
In this region, the
solution is Rlk of r.
That's the solution.
And this solution here, this
is for the l-th partial wave.
The solution outside is
the l-th partial wave
that I've written there.
So the solution here is some
Al Jl of kr plus Bl nl of kr.
So this one you've
determined already.
You did solve the
Schrodinger equation.
We cannot help you.
Now it depends on what
potential you have.
You have to solve it each time.
But you now have the
solution up to A.
But you know the general
form of the solution
for r greater than A, and
these two have to match here.
There might be
cases in which there
is a delta function
precisely here,
like in the p set, in
which case you know
that with a delta function,
the derivatives have
to match in a funny way.
There's a discontinuity
in the derivatives,
and the wave functions
do have to match.
So let's assume, in
general, that there's
no delta function there.
And let's do that case.
If you have a delta function
you could do a similar case.
And the way to do
this is actually
to match the wave functions
and the derivatives.
So matching at r equal a.
So you must have Rlk of a is
equal to Al Jl of ka plus Bl
nl of ka.
The derivatives must also match.
Let me use primes to
indicate derivatives
with respect to the argument.
Most people use that for primes.
So the derivative of this
quantity Rlk a prime--
so that means the
derivative of this function
of r evaluated at a.
And you differentiate
with respect to a in order
to get the units not to change.
You can multiply by an a.
You have to multiply then by
an a on the right-hand side
when I take the derivative.
Now, when I take the derivative
here with respect to r,
I take the derivative of J
with respect to the argument,
and then the relative of the
argument with respect to r.
That takes out the k out.
Since I put an a, I get a
ka times Al J prime l at ka.
The derivative of J with
respect to the argument
evaluated at ka plus
Bl n prime l at ka.
So here it is.
I've matched the function
and the derivatives.
So I'm giving you
an algorithm to do
it any time and all times.
At this point, the
right thing to do
is to divide the
equations because that
gets rid of a lot of things
that we are not interested in.
We're not interested in
anything except the phase shift.
That's all we want,
the phase shift.
So how are we going to
get the phase shift?
Well, the phase shift
comes from Bl over Al.
So let's form the ratio here.
So I'll form the ratio aRlk
prime of a over Rlk at a.
And then I have ka.
That's still there.
And then let me divide--
I'm going to divide
these two things,
but then I can divide the
numerator and the denominator
by Al.
So here I'll have the ratio
of Jl prime ka plus Bl
over Al n prime l of ka over--
my equation came out
a little unbalanced,
but it's not so bad.
ka.
Let's lower this.
OK.
Numerator.
And here you get Jl of ka
plus Bl over Al nl of ka.
But this is nothing but ka
and the ratio Jl prime at ka
minus tan delta k-- no, delta l.
That's what the
ratio Bl over Al is.
n prime l of ka over Jl of
ka minus tan delta l eta.
Not eta.
It's n, actually. n of ka.
That's it.
Actually, we've
solved the problem.
Why?
Because this number is supposed
to be known because you've
solved the equation.
You did solve the equation,
the Schrodinger equation,
from r equals 0 to r equal a.
It's completely solved.
So that number is known.
The Bessel functions,
spherical Bessels, are known.
And all you need to
find is tangent delta,
and that equation determines it.
Should I write the
formula for tangent delta?
OK.
Let's write.
Let's write it.
Yeah.
OK.
One minute to write it.
It's just solving from here.
Tan delta of l is
equal J prime l
at ka minus Rl prime at a
over kRl of k of a Jl of ka
over nl prime at ka minus
Rl prime of a over kRl of a,
that same constant nl of ka.
So that's solving
for tangent delta
from this side
equal to this side.
This shows that, in
principle, once you
have the solution
from 0 to a, you
have solved the problem
of the phase shift.
You know the phase shift.
It's a matter of just
calculating them.
Might be a little messy.
But if your calculation
is important
and this is a problem
you really want to solve,
you will be willing to look
at the spherical Bessel
functions, which, in fact,
are trigonometric functions
times powers.
They're not as difficult as
the ordinary Bessel functions.
So these are easy to work with.
And these things are, many
times, done numerically.
For a given potential, you
calculate the first 10 phase
shifts, and you get a solution
that is very accurate.
So there's a lot of power
in this formulation.
So you have a solution.
You have the phase shifts.